[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin guten Abend der Sport- und
Katja später noch mal mit dem genauen
Blick zur Frauenfußball-WM genau und zum
Tennis unserer Formel 1 schönen guten
Abend hier sind jetzt unsere Themen an
diesem Samstag
AFD Kurt Spitzenkandidat für Europawahl
der sächsische EU-Abgeordnete Krk gehört
zum rechtsaußenlager der Partei
Rhodos kämpft um seine Touristen wegen
der verheerenden Brände haben viele
Veranstalter ihre Reisen storniert und
kommen nur langsam wieder
Französinnen gewinnen WM Spitzenspiel
mit einem 2:1 Sieg gegen Brasilien
meldet sich Frankreichs Team
eindrucksvoll zurück
Tag 2 des afd-parteitages in Magdeburg
heute im Fokus die Europapolitik bzw die
Wahl des Spitzenkandidaten zur
Europawahl Maximilian krass soll es
werden der Anwalt aus Dresden zählt zum
Lager des Rechtsextremisten Björn höcke
und wurde mit deutlicher Mehrheit
gewählt über Europa Kurs Kandidaten und
Stimmung berichtet Andreas Weise
in Magdeburg geht es heute um Europa
EU-Austritt Euro abschaffen Kernthemen
der AFD doch ganz ohne Europa geht es
noch für die Rechtspopulisten nicht zum
Beispiel bei der Migration wir müssen
eine Festung Europa bauen wir brauchen
die Festung Europa zum Schutz unserer
Heimat und das machen wir gemeinsam mit
unseren europäischen Partnern liebe
Freunde
dass man mit den radikalen AFD Europa
Thesen weder hierzulande noch in Brüssel
derzeit mehrheitsfähig ist wissen die
Parteispitzen wohl auch der thüringische
Parteichef Björn höcke erst heute kam
mir nach Magdeburg in der Sache und im
Inhalt sind wir weiterhin deutlich und
klar akzentuiert aber der Prozess ist
natürlich ein organischer das heißt ein
ein sukzessiver und muss angewandt
werden Hauptpunkt heute die Liste für
die Europawahl im kommenden Jahr an der
Spitzen wenn durchaus umstrittener
Kandidat Maximilian krass dass die AFD
in Europa Teil der idee-partei einem
rechtspopulistischen Zusammenschluss dem
unter anderem die FPÖ angehört wird
findet er gut obwohl er selbst schon
mehrfach von der Idee Fraktion in
Brüssel vorübergehen suspendiert wurde
wir wollen in der idee-fraktion bleiben
wir wollen dass Sie größer wird und wir
wollen dass wir so stark werden dass wir
mit entscheiden
die EU von innen heraus auflösen dass
Ziel nicht nur der AFD sondern vieler
Rechtspopulisten EU-weit das und vieles
mehr kritisierten die mehr als 2000 die
heute lautstark in Magdeburg gegen die
AFD Versammlung protestiert werden
für uns in Magdeburg ist Nicole Dietmar
Nicole bislang verläuft der
afd-parteitag eher untypisch geräuschlos
ist die Zeit des offenen Streits vorbei
nun ja die AFD wirkt seit Monaten und
auch hier in Magdeburg nach außen
harmonisch wie selten zuvor das hat man
auch daran gesehen wie glatt die Wahl
das Europawahl Spitzenkandidaten Kah
hier heute über die Bühne gegangen ist
aber fast bis zum Schluss wurde hinter
den Kulissen gerungen denn klar ist
intern hoch umstritten nur wissen hier
alle die aktuellen Rekorde in den
Umfragen sind auch eine Folge der
demonstrativen Geschlossenheit das weiß
auch gern höcke der zwar gegen die
Parteiführung weiter stichelt indem er
zum Beispiel die Auflösung der EU
fordert aber er spricht gleichzeitig von
einem Prozess der sich anbahnen müssen
in Höckers Bundesland Thüringen wird
kommen das Jahr gewählt und deshalb
ordnet Höcker der Machtfrage jetzt
erstmal den von ihm angestrebten Erfolg
unter zusammengefasst kann man also
sagen die AFD streitet weiter aber sie
tut dies im Moment lieber hinter
verschlossenen Türen und mit angezogener
Handbremse danke für die Einschätzung
nach Magdeburg Nicole Diekmann
die USA verstärken ihre Unterstützung
für Taiwan Washington kündigte
Militärhilfe im Wert von
345 Millionen Dollar an damit soll
Taiwan gegenüber China gestärkt werden
die Volksrepublik betrachtet den
demokratischen Inselstaat ja als Teil
des eigenen Territoriums und hat auch
Gewalt nicht ausgeschlossen um es mit
dem Festland zu vereinen den USA wirft
Peking vor Taiwan in ein Pulverfass zu
verwandeln Claudia Bates berichtet
Taiwans Truppen Üben am Strand für den
Ernstfall simulieren einen Überfall
Chinas vom Meer aus die größte jährliche
Militärübung nun verstärken die USA mit
umfassender überwachungs- und
aufklärungsausrüstung und mit Munition
den Schulterschluss sucht die
US-Regierung in der Region auch mit
Australien dort äußert sich der
Außenminister
zum Teil beziehen wir China mit ein aber
wir widersetzen uns dessen Anstrengungen
Überflugrechte im Süd- und
Ostchinesischen Meer einzuschränken und
den Status Quo zu kippen der Frieden und
Stabilität in der Meerenge zwischen
China und Taiwan erhält
dort provoziert China immer wieder im
Juni näherte sich ein chinesisches
Kriegsschiff einem US Zerstörer auf 130
Meter und erst eine Woche zuvor hatte
ein Kampfjet ein amerikanisches
Aufklärungsflugzeug sehr scharf
geschnitten China verurteilt die
us-waffenlieferungen an Taiwan die USA
sollten damit aufhören
wir setzen uns dafür ein dass Taiwan die
Fähigkeiten hat die es braucht um sich
zu verteidigen damit reichen wir nicht
von dem ab was wir auch in der
Vergangenheit getan haben
allerdings wendet der US-Präsident
erstmals für Taiwan eine Regelung an die
es erlaubt auf bestehende
militärbestände der USA zurückzugreifen
als Eskalation sehen US-Experten das
nicht aber
das sendet ein deutliches Signal nach
Peking dass die USA entschlossen sind
Taiwan zu unterstützen und seine
Selbstverteidigung zu stärken seine
Fähigkeiten sich gegen einen
chinesischen Angriff zur Wert zu setzen
und während das taiwanische Militär bei
seinen Übungen erstmals seine
chinesischen Angriff auf den Flughafen
von Taipei simuliert bedankt sich die
Regierung für die Hilfe aus den USA
weniger Kilometer vor der Nordseeinsel
Terschelling bereitet sich das
Bergungsteam darauf vor den in Brand
geratenen autofrachter in sichere
Gewässer zu ziehen das Schiff war
gestern erstmal so weit abgekühlt dass
Experten an Bord gehen und eine stabile
schleppverbindung befestigen konnten
noch am Wochenende soll der Frachter zu
einer sicheren Ankerposition gebracht
werden um ein Auseinanderbrechen oder
Kentern des Schiffes zu verhindern
viel Unmut macht sich breit in einem
Dorf in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern genauer in opal
500 Menschen leben dort und können nicht
verstehen dass hunderte geflüchtete dort
untergebracht werden sollen nach
juristischem hin und her wurde die Zahl
von 400 auf 250 reduziert dennoch gibt
es weiterhin Proteste eine Stadt fällt
berichtet
das Handtuch werfen wollen die Opera auf
keinen Fall ihr Protest gegen einen
Containerdorf für Flüchtlinge geht
weiter im Ortsteil Leben 500 Menschen
250 Asylbewerber hauptsächlich aus
Syrien und Afghanistan sollen hier im
Gewerbegebiet in wenigen Wochen
unterkommen Kritik Sorgen und Ängste
sind vielfältig wir wurden nicht gefragt
Freunde und das gehört sich ja
eigentlich so Hunde wenn in der
Nachbarschaft was passiert dass man die
Nachbarn mit einbezieht man kann ja
keine 250 Leute auf einen Flecken
unterbringen da muss wie großzügig
verteilen einzeln und nicht an einem
Punkt es geht uns ganz Konzept so kriege
ich niemals irgendwelche Leute egal
woher kommen integriert nie das kann
nicht funktionieren die laufen uns doch
um wenn die in Massen
kommen ja bloß 20 30 und da traut sich
keiner nervenstraße bei uns nee das
wollen wir nicht
Hans-peter Voss ist ehrenamtlicher
stellvertretender Bürgermeister in Upahl
ihnen stört das Kreis und Land die
Gemeinde im Vorfeld nicht mit einbezogen
haben Kommunikation die fehlt hier und
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger hier sind ja
ich sage mal DDR sozialisiert die sagen
geht das schon wieder los wir lassen uns
das nicht bieten immer von oben herab
doch der Landrat ist mächtig unter Druck
muss per Gesetz Flüchtlinge aufnehmen
und findet keinen Platz
wir haben da viele Schwierigkeiten auch
weil eben auch die Bereitschaft nicht da
ist
Unterkünfte bereitgestellt bzw dafür
alles zu tun dass wir Unterkünfte
bekommen gegen die Baugenehmigung geht
die Gemeinde gerichtlich vor die Opera
wollen so lange weiter demonstrieren bis
es einen endgültigen Baustopp gibt
wer sich bei uns gerade für eine
Ausbildung bewirbt der hat gute Karten
schließlich fehlen den Unternehmen nicht
nur Fachkräfte sondern eben auch
Nachwuchs die Zahlen belegen es laut
Bundesagentur für Arbeit gab es im Juni
etwa
256.000 freie Ausbildungsplätze dem
gegenüber stehen rund 147.000 die noch
keine Stelle gefunden haben besonders
groß die Lücken im Bau in Metallberufen
oder im Lebensmittelbereich und auch im
Gesundheitswesen herrscht Personalmangel
nicht nur in der Pflege Ende letzten
Jahres waren fast 5000 Arztpraxen nicht
mehr besetzt akut die Situation in
einigen ländlichen Gegenden dort
schließen immer mehr Praxen weil es
keine Nachfolger gibt und so mahnen die
Kassenärzte das Prinzip jedes Dorf ein
Arzt funktioniert einfach nicht mehr
Peter Böhmer
Windheim in der Nähe von Minden 1500
Einwohner einer davon ist Alexander
Blume der hier vor seiner dorfpraxis
steht ein klassischer Landarzt der
pessimistisch nach vorne schauen das
Gesamtsystem ist am kollabieren und das
System bricht langsam vor sich hin
zusammen und das sieht man glaube ich
sehr gut an den fehlenden
facharztterminen an den
nicht mehr vorhandenen Ärzten an den
leeren Hausarztpraxen dr Blume ist mit
47 Jahren jung für einen Hausarzt
55,3 Jahre beträgt deren
Durchschnittsalter 70% sind über 50 in
bloomes Umfeld gibt es 11 Hausärzte 17
wären nur Planung der Kassenärztlichen
Vereinigung möglich Blume sagt mehr Geld
würde den Job attraktiver machen 2 %
mehr Honorar gibt's in diesem Jahr zu
wenig das sind jetzt dieses Jahr zwei
Prozent mehr Honorar bei ungefähr 15%
Kosten Steigerung war schon so avisiert
dass das kann natürlich nicht helfen
weil wenn die Kosten
mehr steigen als mein Honorar dann dann
habe ich ein Minus dann habe ich einen
Verlust
energiematerialkosten Inflation auch
beim Arzt der zur selbstständig ist aber
Preise nicht erhöhen kann doch Experten
sagen Geld ist es nicht allein also wir
werden sicherlich davon Abschied nehmen
von der Idealvorstellung eines
landrattes der in Einzelpraxis in einem
kleineren Dorf tätig ist das wird sich
verlagert in regionale
Gesundheitszentren wo dann mehr
Teilzeitarbeit möglich sein wird weniger
Bereitschaftsdienste für den Einzelnen
und auch mehr kollegialer Austausch das
ist das was im Grunde genommen junge
Studienanfänger heute von ihrer Arbeit
erwarten
1400 Patienten hat Blume pro Quartal 850
sind bundesnetz die Warteliste ist lang
doch neue Patienten nimmt er nur wenn
jemand stirbt oder wegzieht
fast sechs Monate ist das her dass
gewaltige erdbebenteile der Türkei und
Syriens erschütterten mehr als 50.000
Menschen kamen dabei ums Leben viele
viele mehr verloren ihr zu Hause aber
der dringend nötige Wiederaufbau der
stockt unzählige beschädigte Gebäude
müssen nämlich erst einmal abgerissen
werden und über die Schwierigkeiten und
Gesundheitsgefahren dabei berichtet Anna
Feist ja
unterwegs im Erdbebengebiet am Tag ja
eine Stadt die eigentlich Sperrzone sein
sollte 92% der Stadt sind zerstört die
türkische Regierung hat den Wiederaufbau
beschlossen das war Erdogans
Wahlversprechen doch erst müssen alle
Schwerbeschädigten Gebäude abgerissen
werden
dieser Staub ist giftig voller Asbest
Quecksilber und Blei aus dem Mauerwerk
und den elektronischen Geräten die
miteinstürzen deshalb versucht
Bauunternehmer Gökhan Aslan anders als
viele andere in der Stadt den Staub
möglich zu vermeiden bewässert trotz
Wasser Knappheit
selbst wenn wir alles bewässern es ist
unmöglich wirklich ein Staub zu
ersticken der Bauingenieur bringt uns
dorthin wo das Metall aus dem Stein
geholt wird denn das bringe Geld neben
den ohnehin schwierigen
Lebensbedingungen nach dem Leben wird
für die Anwohner nun auch noch der Stadt
zur besonderen Belastung
aber gut und sauber ohne die Menschen zu
belästigen der giftige Bauschutt er
lagert auch auf landwirtschaftlich
genutzten Flächen und selbst am Strand
durch die nachlässig ausgewählten Plätze
seien nun Flüsse küstenfeuchtgebiete und
Grundwasser verseucht warmen Mediziner
und auch der ehemalige Staatssekretär im
Umweltministerium
Erkrankungen und Atemwegsinfektionen
werden zunehmen wir rechnen damit dass
es mehr Fehlgeburten geben wird
Sultan dieser Misere sein die Behörden
sagt östek ermahnt die Schutt halten
schnellstmöglich zu räumen denn schon
jetzt Banner sich in der Region nach der
Katastrophe eine neue Katastrophe an die
die Gesundheit derer kosten könnte die
das Beten überlebt haben
mehr als eine Woche lang wüteten
verheerende Brände in Südeuropa und noch
immer ist die Gefahren nicht überall
gebannt mit Auswirkungen auf Natur und
Tourismus etwa auf der griechischen
Insel Rhodos Tage lang kämpften dort
Einwohner um einzelne Dörfer und rund
20.000 Menschen darunter viele Touristen
mussten vor den Flammen andere wurden
von den Bildern abgeschreckt reisten gar
nicht erst an jetzt kämpft das
Urlaubsparadies um seine Gäste Andreas
poste
Rhodos die Insel der zwei Gesichter
verbrannte Erde auf der einen und
Badespaß auf der anderen Seite
die Touristen im Norden der Insel
bekommen von den verheerenden brennenden
Südosten nichts mit
das fühlt sich ein bisschen seltsam an
wie zwei Welten es gibt zwar die
schlechte Seite aber hier auf dieser
Seite merken wir von all dem nichts
keine Probleme denn es ist viele
Kilometer weit weg von uns hier ist
alles gut kein Problem
12% der Inselfläche sind in Flammen zum
Opfer gefallen so die vorläufige Bilanz
elf Hotels sind betroffen unter die
Angst der einheimischen um das eigene
Hab und Gut mischt sich die Sorge um die
wirtschaftliche Zukunft
[Musik]
dass die Touristen weiter zu uns kommen
es gab viele Stornierungen vor allem der
großen Reiseveranstalter statt bis zu
24.000 Ankünfte pro Tag kam in der
vergangenen Woche kaum noch jemand alle
Hotels der Insel sind davon im
Mitleidenschaft gezogen
insgesamt 100.000 Gäste sind nicht
gekommen wenn das so weitergegangen wäre
wären wir irgendwann bei Null angelangt
doch zum Glück kehren wir gerade zur
Normalität
die
feuer-trolle der Notstand ist aufgehoben
jetzt hoffen sie dass die Touristen
zahlreich auf ihre Sonneninsel
zurückkehren
weltweit hat sich der Klimawandel in
diesem Juli deutlich bemerkbar gemacht
die verschiedenen Wetterphänomene haben
wir in unserer ZDF heute App für Sie
zusammengetragen in einer Bildergalerie
Tornados extrem Hitze Überschwemmungen
vom Saarland bis zu den Philippinen
ein eskalierter Nachbarschaft Streit
steckt offenbar hinter der Blut Tat im
schwäbischen Langweid gestern Abend in
einem Mehrfamilienhaus erschoss ein
64-jähriger sportschützer ein Ehepaar im
Treppenhaus und eine Frau durch die
Wohnungstür später verletzt er in einem
anderen Haus noch zwei weitere Menschen
schwer nach kurzer Fahndung konnte die
Polizei den Mann festnehmen
so jetzt der Sport der mit der
Frauenfußball Weltmeisterschaft beginnt
gut 16 Stunden ist anpfiff im Stadion
von Sydney in der Party Deutschland
gegen Kolumbien das bedeutet dass die
Mannschaft um Bundestrainerin Martina
Voss Tecklenburg heute schon mal Stadion
Luft und rasenduft schnuppern durfte und
es waren alle mit von der Partie
dabei und doch nur Zaungast die
verletzte Außenverteidigerin Felicitas
Rauch in den Katakomben des Stadions von
Sydney während Chantal Hagel die sie
wohl vertreten wird beim
Abschlusstraining unter Beobachtung
stand wir haben immer betont dass wir
klar wissen wie wir unsere
Backup-Funktionen oder Rollen auch
aussehen dass wir das sowieso als Team
im Kollektiv auffangen wollen und müssen
dass es uns eher noch zusammenschweißt
dabei gibt es auch gute Nachrichten Lena
Oberdorf ist wieder spielfit ihre Physis
wird gebraucht gegen robuste
Kolumbianerin wir sind sowas natürlich
auch gewohnt also ist jetzt nicht so
dass wir da große überrascht sind wir
trainieren genauso wie immer trainieren
sie hoffen auf den zweiten Sieg wollen
in die Ko-Runde regeln wollen sie es als
Team
ja und die Schwedinnen haben als drittes
Team das Achtelfinale der WM erreicht
sie gewann jetzt zweites Gruppenspiel
gegen Italien deutlich mit fünf zu Null
und ebenfalls gute Chancen auf das
Achtelfinale als Zweiter der Gruppe F
hat Jamaika nach dem 1:0 Sieg gegen
Panama und das auch weil Brasilien gegen
Frankreich mit 1 zu 2 verloren
bedröppelte Brasilianerinnen in Brisbane
nach einem hochklassigen WM-Spiel gegen
Frankreich den blauen le bleu gelingt in
Minute 17 der Führungstreffer durch
oceanielle Sommer es ist ihr 90
Länderspieltor erst in der zweiten
Hälfte glückt debemia der Ausgleich es
ist ein Spiel auf Augenhöhe äußerst
spannend sieben Minuten vor Ende der
regulären Spielzeit ist es Kapitänin von
dir nach die nach Ecke per Kopf den
Siegtreffer für Frankreich erzielt auch
die danach eingewechselte Martha kann
die Niederlage nicht verhindern
Frankreich triumphiert
hat auch Tennis Tennisprofi Alexanders
er steht im Endspiel des ATP Turniers in
Hamburg er gewann vor wenigen Minuten
gegen den Franzosen natürlich fies mit
6:224 und spielt morgen gegen den Serben
Laszlo Jere und bei den Frauen hat
Nummer nur akukur den ersten Titel
gewinnen einer deutschen Tennisspielerin
am Hamburger roten Baum seit Steffi Graf
1992 verpasst die 19-Jährige aus Reinbek
verlor bei ihrem ersten bta-turnier nach
einer sensationellen Woche im Finale
gegen die Niederländerin arancarus mit 0
zu 6 und 6 7
und in der Formel 1 hat WM Spitzenreiter
Max Verstappen auch das Sprint-Rennen in
Spa Belgien gewonnen das wegen starken
Regens immer wieder verschoben werden
musste er baute damit seine Führung in
der WM auf 118 Punkte Vorsprung vor Red
Bull Team-Kollege Peres aus morgen
Nachmittag dann das nächste Rennen in
den Ardennen
und schon heute Abend das aktuelle
sportstudio mit zwei Rekord
Leichtathleten mit Jochen Breyer und das
ganze um 23 Uhr vielen Dank Katja
Poolbesitzer die kennen das vielleicht
mit eigenem Becken hat man im Sommer
gerne mal viele Gäste Gebet ne und
manchmal auch ungebeten ne aber einfach
rausschmeißen das sagt sich so leicht
vor allem wenn der Gast sich gerade so
richtig gut gehen lässt wie dieser Bär
hier bei Los Angeles 5 Minuten hat das
die sich im Wasser geregt erzählt der
Besitzer sei dann auf einen Baum
geklettert und dort ganz entspannt
weggelegt süß
so Regenschauer Gewitter aber auch mal
länger Sonne bei 19 bis 25 Grad mehr
Wetter hat gleich Katja horneffer das
heute journal heute gegen 22:40 Uhr mit
Dunja Hayali schönen Abend schönen Dank
und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend was heute besonders an den
Hochsommer erinnerte waren die kräftigen
Regenschauer und Gewitter die über
Baden-Württemberg und Bayern gezogen
sind aber auch über die Mittelgebirge
über Niedersachsen über
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Berlin und
Brandenburg und mit diesen Gewittern die
zum Teil heftig ausgefallen sind also
mit Hagel Platzregen und sturmböden
verbunden waren haben wir es auch noch
am Abend zu tun in der Nacht aber ziehen
sie immer mehr nach Osten ab aber in der
zweiten Nachthälfte kommen neue Schauer
und Gewitter von Frankreich und aus der
Schweiz her bei uns an bei Südwestwind
die Temperaturen sinken auf 17 bis 11
Grad und liegen morgen in den Bergen
genauso wie an der Nordseeküste bei 19
bis 20 Grad sonst werden bis zu 25 Grad
erreicht und am Vormittag gibt's noch
Regenschauer die ziehen ja langsam
ostwärts ab und dann gibt es erstmal ein
sehr freundlichen Streifen von der
Ostseeküste bis zum Oberrhein in
Nordwesten allerdings werden die Wolken
schon Dichter bringen Regenschauer und
Gewitter mit und die breiten sich dann
am Nachmittag weiter in Richtung
Südosten aus dann wird's in
Baden-Württemberg recht heute
am Montag kann es dann vor allen Dingen
im Norden kräftig regnen danach geht es
einfach wechselhaft weiter schönes
Wochenende